What if I had a big pizza party with
lots of friends and lots of different
kinds of pizza and at the end of
the party there were lots of leftovers.
And I had the choice to take home
three-eighths of the anchovy pizza or
five-sixteenths of the pepperoni pizza.
Which one should I take home if I want
as much leftover pizza as possible.
How do I compare three-eights and
five-sixteenths?
One way we can compare three-eighths and
five-sixteenths is using a number line.
Here's our number line and
notice that it goes from zero to one.
On this number line please
select where three-eighths and
five-sixteenths should fall.
So you'll be selecting two boxes and
just as a little hint,
each of these little tick
marks is one-sixteenth.